NOTHING-NOTHING GAME.
ACROBATIC GOALTENDING EXPECTED
ALL AFTERN
MORNING SKATE PRACTICE WHERE
ORLOV IS IN THE GOOD LOOK FOR
THE WASHINGTON CAPITALS.
"OVIE" RIGHT JENSEN STALKED ON
THE  BEAT THE SIDE THE CAPITALS
A LITTLE MIX-UP, AND IT TURNED S
BENCH.
GETS
PLAY!
NOW ONE SHY OF ANDREWCHUCK!
HKI
HARD TO THE NET.
GOAL SCORERS Joe:  OVECHKIN FIR
BOBBY.
A BODY BLOW.
"OVIE" ON THE BOARD  LAST 7. THA
REINHART-LOOKING
CREDIT TO WEEGAR JUMPING UP IN
THE PLAY.
THEY'RE CLOSE TO BEING I DON'T
HAVE SIDES, BUT T  WITH A
LITTLE HELP.
PA HERE IT IS.
NOW, I GUESS HE DID FALL LONG
TO REENGAG LAST PLAY.
KUZNETSOV TOHATS FOR ALEX
OVECHKIN! S DAY, YOU LEAVE
"OVIE" LIKE THAT, AND IT'S 10
OUT OF 10 FOY IN CHARGE AND
HAD ALL OFSTEP UP.
THEY'RE IN CONTROL.
IT'S LIKE ONE ON THREE, AND HE
FLORIDA, HUBERDEAU FIRES!
GOOD STOP THERE.
SAMSONOV ON THE ANKLE.
THIS IS BANKED DOWN  AGAIN